did you see an interview with Andy
Wachowski who's one of the guys behind
the Matrix movies and he and his brother
both became trans at a certain but kind
of odd the guys who created The Matrix
about this disconnect between reality
and the virtual reality these guys both
become trans and Andy Wachowski one of
the brothers gives an interview and and
he says oh yeah porn was what led me to
my transgender identity I watched a
bunch of porn and then I started
identifying as trans and there were
there were many such cases well Ted
Bundy Ted Bundy was super into porn
right yeah very into porn and he
actually said porn was the thing that
led him to this thing and this thing and
this thing and then I mean that's the
way it is like you you know you at one
point in my life I could drink one Bud
Light and get a buzz you know and then
you know you need more to just crack
even crystal meth or something yeah like
you you go on this trajectory where I
need more of this thing to get this
feeling that I had